well let's look at the progress of this
war from the failed attempt to take key
to the grinding slug of the battle in
the don bass dw reporter joel dolroy has
been looking at russia's changing
military goals
well during the three and a half months
of russia's invasion of ukraine the
front line has shifted dramatically
russia's initial attempt focused on the
capital of kiev and the second biggest
city of kharkiv but the ukrainian
military surprised their world with
their defiant resistance pushing the
underprepared russians back
after leaving kiev they focused most of
their units on the south and east and
focused their efforts instead on taking
full control of the donbass region the
port city of mariupol also became a
major flash point ukrainian troops held
out there longer than anyone expected
under terrible conditions but finally
surrendered in may
well after months of strong ukrainian
resistance western military analysts say
that russia is now regaining some
traction russia's defense minister this
week claimed success in being able to
open up rail connections between the
occupied crimea peninsula and russia
much of the recent fighting has been
focused on the city of saviero donetsk
which is a major chemical production
industry and it's a gateway to the rest
of the donbas
western military analysts say that
russia is encircling ukrainian troops in
what is being called a cauldron
ukraine's own military commanders say
that they are outnumbered there five to
one and fighting is going on block by
block
some analysts say that ukraine appears
to have given up attempts to hold the
city and is instead trying to inflict
what damage they can on the surrounding
troops
the situation in seviero donetsk is
looking increasingly dire the mayor says
the city has been reduced to a bombed
out wasteland with some ten thousand
civilians trapped and unable to evacuate
residents there are reportedly
sheltering in a chemical plant in an
eerie echo of what happened in mariupol
the past week of the russian resurgence
has shown us that neither side can yet
comfortably claim to have the upper hand
and that seeming victories can quickly
turn to disappointing setbacks phil joel
thank you joel delray
western countries have condemned the
death sentences given to three foreign
fighters by a pro-russia court the court
in the self-proclaimed dinette people's
republic said the men are mercenaries
paid by kiev
the two britons and the moroccan are the
first foreign soldiers to be tried by
ukraine's russia-backed rebels ukraine
and the west have denounced the trial
describing it as a sham and a violation
of the rules of war
let's go straight to dw correspondent
nick connolly who joins us from
mikhailev in southern ukraine welcome
anik so first of all tell us about the
court that passed these death sentences
well this is a court formally uh run by
the rush-back separatists in donetsk
who've been in place since 2014
these are essentially russian proxies uh
even in recent weeks we've seen even
more direct russian control of uh these
authorities with people who've been
governors and other top officials in
russia being sent directly to run uh
things on the ground there we're hearing
talk out of moscow that moscow will soon
aim to annex uh officially uh donaire's
glohansk regions may be adding the bits
of zaporiza and her son obviously in the
south of ukraine that they have been
able to occupy since the 24th of
february so the idea that this is
somehow an independent court that it's
able to do anything against the wishes
or without a direct instruction moscow
is barely credible as basically not real
so this is it seems an attempt to scare
people who are coming from
mainly western countries to ukraine to
fight on ukraine's side it's part of the
propaganda war it's maybe trying to
raise the stakes and maybe get some kind
of deal longer term to get more russian
prisoners back in return but there's no
real sense that this is anything
except a pr move and something to try
and uh really scare people who've been
thinking about coming here
and people have been thinking about
going there after president zielenski
invited um
foreigners to come and fight when the
war started how significant a role are
foreign fighters playing in this war
it's difficult to get concrete figures
on how many people have actually come
how many people have actually stayed but
i think it's important for two reasons
initially it was about morale building
for ukraine the sense that ukraine even
though it was outside nato outside the
eu that ukraine isn't on its own the
people around the world are paying
attention that they care and they're
even willing to risk their lives to help
ukrainians following this russian
invasion and there's the second part
which is about technical knowledge lots
of these people have backgrounds in
nato militaries and now that ukraine is
basically forced to
learn to use this equipment they're
getting from the u.s the uk and other
countries in very short spaces of time
but basically all their soviet era
weaponry has been used up in the past
three months they're now just using the
attila systems that they're given
because literally their their storage
units are empty that's the intensity of
the war here so having people who've
used these
different types of equipment in battle
situations incredibly useful to the
ukrainian army that's basically training
that's happening on the ground
inefficiently because obviously the
training provided by the uk and the u.s
officially that is not happening in
country you're having ukrainian officers
having to leave the country to learn to
use different bits of kit so that's
that's the kind of importance of that um
as for the claim that these are
mercenaries by that uh dunya's court
well that's also not doesn't hold up
given the wages in ukraine's army these
people are getting official ukrainian
army wages they are
very very modest by western standards so
this is not a country not a conflict
where anyone would turn up for the money
this is definitely uh for people who are
coming here for for the idea for the uh
for you know the symbolism of it
and the fighting of course is continuing
both where you are there in the south
and of course in donbass
well that's the extraordinary thing i'm
here making a live about 20 kilometers
away from me uh some extraordinarily uh
intense fighting going on artillery
battles the ukrainians actually in this
part of the country forcing the russians
back because the russians have focused
all their attentions there on donbass
around the city of seville donetsk
basically throwing everything they have
at a very small part of the front lines
the russians are making progress but at
much slower pace than they'd expected uh
basically a question of hundreds of
meters a day not more than that uh we've
been hearing reports from seven nets for
weeks now that everyone expecting it to
fall to russians finally you know
tomorrow day after it's just not
happening for now the ukrainians are
holding up but obviously they are
outgunned and outmanned at least in
donbass thanks nick dw correspondent
nick connolly in michaelave
now the sentencing of those three men is
certain to raise concerns for the fate
of other captured foreign fighters as
early as february the 27th ukraine
announced the formation of a foreign
legion many of those who enlisted came
from neighbouring belarus they now see
ukraine as their only means of fighting
vladimir putin's growing influence we've
got more now from dw correspondent
matthias bullinger
there are no bullets today but soon
these men will be fighting for their
future against the russian army in the
south and east
they are serving in the ukrainian army
but they're all from belarus
alexey joined up eight years ago after
the maidan protests when the conflict in
the east started
ukraine is one of the last free
countries of the former soviet union
if ukraine had lost its freedom during
the maidan protests if they had been
repressed there would be no future
there are now several hundred bella
russian fighters in ukraine enough to
form a regiment many fled their homes in
2020 when belarus dictator alexander
lukashenko cracked down on huge
demonstrations against him
this man who didn't want to be
identified by name took part in the
protests
we were hoping to overthrow
by peaceful means
the idea is that the bella russian
regime is so closely tied to russia that
a defeat for putin would also be a
defeat for lukashenko for these fighters
the war in ukraine is also about the
future of their country
and they can't go home until things
change
i mean
a lifelong imprisonment would await me
there
at the worst
execution
they could pin extremism on me for
taking part in the protests in 2020 and
on top of that now they'd charge me as a
mercenary for taking part in the war
alexey was injured during the second
week of the war
he was on a reconnaissance mission in
bucha when a shell blew away his leg
for now he trains new recruits waiting
for a better prosthetic leg that will
enable him to serve closer to the front
again
i never thought that i made my sacrifice
and that would be it people make
sacrifices every day at the front that's
life that's war
it may be a long way to go but he says
retiring from active duty is not an
option
we can speak now to frank ledwich who's
a former british military officer now
our military analyst he joins us from
oxford england frank good to see you i
want to ask you about these belarusian
fighters in in a moment but more broadly
speaking what has been the role of
foreign armed groups in this war
well jared since the start and the start
really was 2014 this this war has been
heavily internationalized especially by
the ukrainian side so the international
legion for territorial defense which jan
phillip was talking about is composed of
several nationalities the belarusians of
course we've already spoken about we'll
talk about soon we've got the georgians
there another very significant group and
the chechens bizarrely there are two
chechen battalions
on the russian side they too have been
trying trying hard to get other
nationalities in mainly through the
means of mercenaries uh the ukrainians
reported they killed about 15 syrians
down in donbass a couple of months ago
but they've obviously failed to to get
the manpower they need that but on the
ukrainian side yet there's quite a
significant involvement of international
troops
how close are the formal ties between
this belarusian militia group and the
ukrainian armed forces
well in general the international legion
is part of the armed force and of course
that plays back into these war crimes so
called war triumph crimes trials the
russians are
conducting now uh so they're part of the
ukrainian army the legion is and it's
composed of several battalions in the
case of the belarusians they were
incorporated formally the kalinowski
battalion were incorporated formally in
march into the ukrainian army and
they're now recruiting another battalion
uh the uh pahonia battalion so they're
they're very integrated they're part of
the ukrainian armed forces they're part
of the army
they are integrated as you say now they
are serving in the ukrainian army do the
members of this belarusian unit have
designs on possibly undermining the
regime back home in belarus
well journalist i understand it their
motto is first ukraine then belarus
which would uh perhaps provide an answer
to that but the political background i
think i think that this should be well
understood in belarus is rather
different from other or some other
former soviet states only different than
russia
uh in that it is it is it's got a
heavily independent minded opposition
and as we saw last year that opposition
is very strong and consequently belarus
belarus
pole show
is quite supportive
very supportive actually of ukraine
and we've seen sabotage in southern
belarus so that's the political
background to the to the belarus belarus
regiment as it now is of two battalions
so the answer is yes their objective is
overthrow lukashenko
and uh what do we know exactly about how
how the fighters have been deployed in
ukraine
not too much the ukrainians are quite
understandably very caged about pretty
much everything they do and that's right
but as far as we know as jan phillips
said the foreign fighters are in general
are
somewhere between i think probably
around twenty thousand
that's the best number whether all of
those are as was hinted effective combat
troops is a slightly different thing
some of them may be in the rear and
guard you two it's still very useful but
it seems that they're they're
deployed largely as light infantry and
reconnaissance troops so they're not
they don't have artillery or tanks or
armor or anything like that as far as we
know
that's our military analyst frank lidwig
frank it's been great to talk to you
thank you very much
thank you jared
and the rush of former soviet states
applying for membership of the european
union it appears georgia's application
has been pushed behind those of ukraine
and moldova that's according to internal
eu documents seen by dw news the three
countries are all waiting for the
european commission to deliver its
recommendations to heads of government
on the 23rd of june
we'll talk to jack parrock in brussels
who's had exclusive access to this
document welcome jack what more can you
tell us
hi phil indeed so we've got our hands on
a bit of a snippet of a document which
which essentially says that the european
commission could make a distinction
between moldova ukraine and georgia
whereby only the first two would be
granted eu candidate status so this is a
this is pretty important actually
because all three of these countries
applied to become eu candidate countries
in the wake of the invasion
of ukraine by russia at the beginning of
march they made those applications
brussels has told all three countries
but specifically ukraine that they will
use a fast-track process that they will
try and move this as quickly as possible
but it's now seeming that the process
for all three is going to be a little
bit more complicated
now also in this document what we can
read is that the european commission is
also considering only granting the
country's candidate status
rather than beginning the negotiations
for them to become accession countries
in order to become a european union
country each government has to negotiate
32 what are known as chapters and they
get opened as a chapter so this could be
on economic cooperation or rule of law
and they negotiate those issues the
european union checks that they're in
line with the values of the eu and then
the chapter gets closed and 32 of them
need to happen now what we're seeing is
potentially in this document that the
european commission is going to tell
leaders at the summit on the 23rd and
24th that they should be granted
candidate status
but that they wouldn't be opening and
closing those chapters and actually
getting into the nitty-gritty of the
negotiations so that is also not great
uh for the governments in moldova and
ukraine as well
so so when are we likely to see moldova
and ukraine actually join the eu
well it all looks like a long way off
and it looks like this fast track that
was promised is starting to stumble when
you look at other countries it's
interesting that uh at this eu summit
here in brussels at the end of june
there will also be countries from the
western leaders from the western balkans
including north macedonia which became
for instance a candidate country in 2005
but it's still waiting for it's a a it's
a process negotiation process for those
negotiations
to be opened as well i think what's
significant here as well with with
regard to georgia as well is it's
important to say that there there is
some there is a lot of concern here in
brussels about that specific application
georgia in the last few years has
really aligned itself economically with
the rest of the european union as part
of a deep and free trade agreement that
was that was signed but here in brussels
there's real concern about the political
status in the country back in 2018
during an election there was widespread
accusations of major mass vote buying
and in brussels they're worried about
that and i think while the georgians
will be very unhappy to hear this
and especially if it does come to light
in the coming weeks i think it is
somewhat predictable from the european
commission who's going to start opening
up these opinions and we'll start to
hear them more publicly within a week or
so phil okay thank you for that jack
jack parrok in brussels
moscow's chief rabbi is reportedly
staying out of russia because of fears
that his support for ukrainian refugees
has angered the kremlin the conference
of european rabbis says pinkass a
goldsmith was advised not to return from
a trip to hungary in israel where he'd
been raising money to assist refugees
now his whereabouts are unknown at a
conference meeting in munich this month
he told the dw that many russian jews
have left the country or are considering
doing so
let's take a closer look at this with
dw's religious affairs correspondent
martin gack welcome martin phil
is the war having a particular uh impact
on on russia's jewish community
it seems to be actually quite a strong
impact i mean it's a story that has been
more or less underground we have been
mostly focusing uh in the religious desk
in any case i mean on the orthodox issue
and the relation with the vatican but
the fact is that the
jewish community has also been
transversed by this among other things
because there is a very important jewish
community in russia part of it is very
close to the kremlin part of it
and there is also a very strong and very
important jewish community
in the ukraine in ukraine sorry so
the fact is that there is a lot of
discomfort and there seems to be a lot
of uncertainty
i talked personally with the
organization with the european
conference of rabbis yesterday and the
claim is that
the community is actually very concerned
they do not report any uptick on
anti-semitism or anything of the kind
but there is there seems to be a lot of
concern
and so tell us more then about the
complicated situation jews have faced in
russia especially in the years after
putin
i mean the issue at this stage is that
the russian community has a very strong
relation with the ukrainian community as
a matter of fact for instance one of the
main most important rivals of of kiev
is actually russian-born
you know we have lasad who is a habat
lubavitch is one of a very important
orthodox orthodox group who is very very
close to putin
but there is also in the same group sort
of a lot of rabbis operating in poland
operating in ukraine what that meant is
essentially that you know as every other
religious group
essentially people that are
a clergy that is very close to the
kremlin finds itself at arts with clergy
that is on the receiving end of this war
and this operation okay so jews of
course not the only group confronted by
big questions because of this war what
about other groups such as the orthodox
church and indeed muslim communities
well the orthodox church has been the
one that we've been following the
closest and in fact i mean we have seen
nothing short of schism so i mean the
the ukrainian church has essentially
broken away the russian orthodox church
of ukraine has broken away from the
moscow battlegate
the muslim community has seen its own
sort of you know break i mean we have
seen
muslim fighters chechen fighters running
into places like madupo only a couple of
weeks after the mario paul mosque and
the maripo
muslim community was essentially sitting
under russian bombs what we're seeing
now with this story is that
that break is really just transversing
all religious groupings and i think it's
essentially as i just said it's doing it
for the very same reason which is that
we have strong religious commitments but
with a strong sort of element of
religious identity around the question
of the conflict and that has actually
divided the waters quite radically in
this case okay thank you for that martin
gack dw's religious affairs
correspondent thank you